y
[Música]
hola muy buenas noches bienvenidos a
kobe 19 la semana en américa soy
santiago lópez gonzález y este es el
espacio de france 24 en el que hacemos
un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
de kobe 19 en nuestro continente a
continuación algunos de los temas que
vamos a tratar en este programa
la variante o microonda ya hace
presencia en el continente americano
canadá fue el primer país en reportar
casos y méxico es el último hasta ahora
en la región que ha alertado sobre casos
en su territorio las investigaciones en
torno a esta variante todavía están en
marcha y es muy poca la información que
tenemos sobre ella mientras tanto la
innovación
o el llamado es a guardar la calma y a
seguir cuidándose en unos minutos les
estaremos contando cómo está la
situación en nuestro continente en torno
a esta nueva variante perú brasil y
méxico son los primeros países en
américa latina que han reportado casos
de la variante omicron veremos qué
medidas han tomado algunos de los países
de la región de manera preventiva hasta
tanto no se tenga más información sobre
esta nueva variante y hoy nos acompaña
en el estudio de france 24 el doctor
carlos eduardo pérez para nuestra
habitual consulta en nuestra agenda por
supuesto hablaremos de la variante
omicron el debate que habrá en europa
ante la posibilidad de instaurar la
obligatoriedad de las vacunas y también
sobre la vida de las vacunas también
tenemos otros temas en unos minutos
vamos a conversar con el doctor pérez
aquí en el programa vamos a comenzar y
entonces y lo hacemos con las cifras lo
hacemos viendo cómo está el panorama
cómo está avanzando la pandemia de kobe
19 nuestro continente vamos entonces
directamente a ver cómo está la
situación en méxico en donde cierran
esta semana con 38 millones de casos son
cifras desde el inicio de la pandemia y
más de 294.000 personas han fallecido
nos vamos hasta el salvador- terminaron
esta semana con más de 119 mil casos y
más de 3700 personas han fallecido allí
en este país centroamericano colombia
tiene 5,4 millones de casos registrados
y finaliza esta semana con más de 128
mil fallecidos bolivia reporta más de
540 mil casos y más de 19 mil fallecidos
finalizamos en brasil el gigante
suramericano este país tiene 22 1 millón
millones de casos ya confirmados y más
de 615 mil personas han fallecido en ese
país
bueno pues sin ánimo de generar alarma
varios países latinoamericanos han
tomado algunas medidas para evitar el
avance de la variante omicron o al menos
para ganar tiempo hasta tanto se conozca
un poco más de información sobre esta
variante van desde restricciones de los
vuelos hasta la exigencia de un pase
sanitario o simplemente instar a
vacunarse y a ponerse la dosis de
refuerzo así han reaccionado algunas de
las autoridades en los diferentes países
de américa latina veamos
omicron una variante aún en estudio y
toniet know whether omicron is asustéis
todavía no sabemos si omicron está
asociado con una mayor transmisión una
enfermedad más grave más riesgo de
infección o más riesgo de evadir las
vacunas vaccines
santis los científicos de la uv ms de
todo el mundo están trabajando
urgentemente para responder a estas
preguntas les qüestions a pesar del
anuncio de la o ms latinoamérica impone
restricciones para evitar el avance de
omicron a partir del 4 de diciembre los
viajeros que lleguen a cuba desde
sudáfrica botsuana lesoto eso a tiny tim
bauer namibia malawi y mozambique deben
además de estar vacunados cumplir con
otros requisitos para entrar a la isla
procedente de tu país se le tomará una
muestra debe ser en el momento del
arribo como sabemos que se hacía hasta
hace 1 unas semanas anteriores
se le va a aplicar o se aplicará una
cuarentena obligatoria por siete días la
nación caribeña dependiente en gran
parte del turismo reabrió hace solo dos
semanas sus fronteras a los visitantes
internacionales brasil es el segundo
país más afectado del mundo por el kobe
19 con más de 614 mil muertes cerrará
sus fronteras a los viajeros que lleguen
de 6 países del sur de áfrica es una
variante que nos preocupa pero no es una
variante que nos tiene desesperados en
argentina las personas que hayan estado
en áfrica en los últimos 14 días deberán
permanecer en aislamiento durante otros
14 días incluso si están completamente
vacunadas
además habrá restricción de buenos
nosotros si vamos a reiniciar los vuelos
por una aerolínea directa estropean
airlines a mediados de diciembre vamos a
postergar ese inicio de los vuelos
directos y chile también impondrá una
prohibición de viaje a pasajeros
provenientes de países africanos el
presidente mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador dio un parte de tranquilidad con
respecto a la variante y no anunció
restricciones sobre esta variante
y decirle a todos los mexicanos que
estamos
llevando a cabo un seguimiento
qué
no hay
elementos para
preocuparnos en perú donde ya hay
presencia de la variante omicron las
personas provenientes de sudáfrica
deberán presentar una prueba pcr
negativa no mayor a 48 horas y de estar
completamente vacunas
bueno ahora veamos cómo está para el
cierre de la semana los reportes de los
primeros casos de la variante omicron en
nuestro continente ya lo decíamos el
primer país en reportar casos fue canadá
pero también ya eeuu méxico brasil y
perú han reportado haber encontrado
algunos pacientes con esta variante a
los cuales les están haciendo un
seguimiento pertinente por parte de las
autoridades sanitarias
y aunque ahora hablamos de la variante o
micro en la variante delta sigue siendo
la variante predominante en buena parte
de nuestro planeta sin embargo la ms
instó a las farmacéuticas a estar
preparadas para enfrentar a las nuevas y
posibles variantes que puedan aparecer
en un futuro cercano veamos estar un
paso adelante del virus es la estrategia
que propone la o ms para ganarle la
batalla a la pandemia
es muy recomendable que los fabricantes
de vacunas comiencen a planificar con
anticipación ante la probabilidad de
tener que ajustar las vacunas ya
existentes
no está bien tener que esperar hasta el
final para reaccionar
grings la llegada de la variante omicron
que avanza su camino por los cinco
continentes por un aviso de alerta a los
sistemas de salud en todo el mundo pero
aún no hay que perder de vista a la
variante delta en francia uno de los
países de europa donde este linaje ataca
con fuerza ya se prevé el pico de la
nueva ola a finales de enero la quinta
ola relacionada con la variante delta se
está extendiendo rápidamente 50.000
casos nuevos cada día es mucho tiene un
impacto muy notable en existe en francia
en este momento una persona ingresa en
cuidados intensivos cada 10 minutos lo
ms instó a los países a concentrar
esfuerzos para avanzar en la vacunación
y así frenar más contagios de esta
variante recordemos que delta representa
actualmente el 99 por ciento de las
infecciones en todo el mundo según 16 la
base de datos de todas las secuencias
del genoma mientras se terminan de
comprender los alcances de la variante y
los expertos explican que las
restricciones de viaje pueden frenar
momentáneamente la diseminación de
omicron pero no sólo una solución
definitiva o micro no delta las
autoridades sanitarias se enfatizan que
es importante no entrar en pánico
vamos ahora a conversar con el doctor
carlos eduardo pérez él es médico
infectólogo y asesor científico de
france 24 ya está con nosotros aquí en
el estudio de france 24 para nuestra
consulta doctor bienvenido un gusto
tenerlo acá con nosotros ya en persona
que en el estudio de france 24
bienvenido bienvenido y quiero comenzar
preguntándole por la variante omicron
que es el tema central del programa de
hoy quien novedades hay en la comunidad
médica y científica en torno a la
investigación que está avanzando sobre
esta variante estas variantes la
variante omicron y otras variantes que
se puedan desarrollar son el fruto de
personas que son susceptibles se siguen
continuando el virus en su proceso
evolutivo de la mutación lo que
conocemos es que las mutaciones
acumuladas
incrementan la transmisibilidad aún no
está preciso si aumentan la letalidad es
decir su capacidad de enfermar o si
involucra alguna resistencia a las
vacunas es probable que disminuya la
actividad de algunas pero eso todavía no
está establecido las informaciones
preliminares hablan que necesitamos
testear más a más personas con las
vacunas y es probable que al final de la
otra semana tenemos información al
respecto doctor en cuanto a la vacuna
que se sabe de las vacunas que hay
disponibles funcionan para atacar esta
variante esta nueva variante o que se
sabe sobre ellas definitivamente va a
estar mejor estar vacunado que no estar
vacunado nunca va a ser el mismo terreno
de una persona vacunada y que ya el
sistema inmunológico conozca al virus a
una persona que nunca ha recibido una
vacuna y que tanto va a funcionar y
neutralizar es los anticuerpos o cuánto
van a durar esto había una duda que hay
más preguntas que respuestas en este
momento y no micro en algunos reportes
de hoy hablan de que si hay un proceso
de neutralización por parte de las
vacunas actuales pero todo es muy
prematuro decirlo hay que guardar la
sensatez estar tranquilos estar
pendiente de la información pero
definitivamente es mucho mejor estar
vacunado que no estarlo nunca va a ser
diferente una persona no vacuna va a
estar mucho más susceptible a esta oa
cualquier otra variante claro lo mejor
estar entonces vacunado y seguir
cuidándose como lo hemos venido haciendo
a lo largo de todos estos meses
lavándonos las manos usando
y también
guardando el distanciamiento entre
personas quiero cambiar de tema hablemos
ahora de ese eterno debate llevamos dos
años hablando de la obligatoriedad de
las vacunas ante el escenario que se
está presentando en europa varios países
ya lo están planteando por lo menos
están considerando dentro de algunos de
los gobiernos y la unión europea dijo
creo que nos va a tocar sentarnos a los
27 países a dialogar y mirar si va a ser
necesario volver obligatoria la
vacunación dentro de la unión europea
esto definitivamente es la mejor
solución para garantizar una inmunidad
para acabar con esta pandemia rápido
este como lo ve claro la vacunación
tiene que ser masiva y tiene que ser a
todo el mundo nosotros pensamos que es
cumpliendo un número mágico del 70% pero
realmente es el 90 o 98 por ciento del
planeta que estar vacunado todos los
esfuerzos para que la vacunación sea
masiva son válidos y recordar que la
vacuna no es un acto individual es un
acto de responsabilidad social nosotros
no nos vacunamos para proteger nuestra
salud sino también para proteger la
salud de los demás este es un acto que
es de colaboración la vacuna como un
capullo que nos involucra a todos para
protegernos a todos entonces la
vacunación si debe ser masiva
obviamente usar todas las herramientas
que sean posible y yo sí soy partidario
de que haya vacunación en la obligatoria
en la mayoría de las veces además que ya
ya lo hemos visto la vacuna no va a
evitar que nos dé el virus pero sí va a
hacer que sea un poco más leve y evitar
que lleguemos a instancias de entrar a
una uci o estar entubados y tener
asistencia para poder sobrellevar esta
situación además que también la umh se
ha dicho que no han comprobado que
ninguna de las muertes recientes estén
relacionadas con la variante omicron
entonces a lo mejor ahí tenemos un poco
ganado el terreno doctor en paraguay y
esta es una noticia que vamos a
desarrollar más adelante aquí en el
programa anunciaron la destrucción de un
lote de vacunas porque éstas se
vencieron las autoridades sanitarias
incluso tenían un poco de vergüenza por
tener que hacer este anuncio y es porque
la gente no ha ido a vacunarse pero
entonces eso lleva mi pregunta a asia
cual es la caducidad o la vida útil de
una vacuna si éstas permanecen
congeladas las vacunas requieren proceso
de almacenamiento que tiene que estar
relacionado con la cadena de frío quad y
esto no es un medicamento ilimitado en
el tiempo tal vez sea unos años su vida
útil algunos meses por eso cuando se
está para ampliar de vacunas se debe
usar inmediatamente no se pueden guardar
las vacunas cuando se almacenan por
largo tiempo pues se pierden y lo que
hemos perdido en muchas ocasiones es que
la gente esperando una marca de una
vacuna se pierden las vacunas que siguen
todas son efectivas y se tienen que
desechar pero hay muchas personas que
pueden acceder a estas vacunas que se ha
perdido la oportunidad habitantes de
calle personas que son recicladores
personas de la informalidad pueden
recibir este tipo de vacunas no sería
desperdicio desperdiciar ningún
biológico eso habla de la gestión de la
salud pública de cada uno de los países
y también de la educación hacia la
inmunización que requerimos en toda la
región nosotros tenemos un déficit
aunque vamos mucho mejor que europa
todavía muy importante y mientras haya
personas susceptibles va a haber
mutaciones va a haber variantes y así
tengamos en cuenta algunas cada uno
funcionar nos vacunamos todos o esto no
funciona hay muchas zonas remotas en el
continente americano donde todavía no ha
llegado ningún tipo de vacunas para
terminar doctor hablemos de esa píldora
de la farmacéutica merck ellos
anunciaron esta semana que esta píldora
es completamente efectiva para todo tipo
de
de los tipos de las variantes de kobe 19
que hay y que han aparecido hasta el
momento que se sabe de esta píldora
recordemos que esta píldora funciona
sobre la reproducción de los coronavirus
no específicamente el sars scope 2
aunque sí su particularidad y no tiene
que ver con la proteína espiga es decir
las vacunas actúan sobre una proteína es
los medicamentos actúan sobre otro
target sobre otro objetivo completamente
distinto tanto el medicamente facer como
el medicamento de merck actúan en sitios
distintos que no tienen que ver con
estas mutaciones y lo que hace suponer
es que neutralizan estos virus también
se está trabajando una vacuna que no va
a ser independientemente de los
genotipos va a relacionarse con un punto
específico que es común a los
coronavirus y que probablemente sea la
respuesta digamos que la ciencia está
respondiendo los medicamentos son son
efectivos los anticuerpos monoclonales
han mostrado su efectiva contra estas
nuevas variantes y es probable que la
vacuna funcione y si no hay que hacerle
algunos ajustes para hacer la regulación
doctor muchas gracias por haber estado
con nosotros aquí en el programa
habernos aquí en el estudio es un gusto
como siempre conversar con usted aclarar
todas estas dudas ya que da el panorama
mucho más claro para todos vamos a ver
ahora como avanzado la vacunación en el
continente americano les presento a
continuación el porcentaje de la
población con esquema de vacunación
completo y con una dosis y también pues
por supuesto el porcentaje total de la
población que está vacunado demos un
vistazo entonces a las cifras de mexico
allá el 50 por ciento de la población ya
tiene dos dosis completas una dosis el 9
40 por ciento esto es para un total de
59 por ciento de la población inmunizada
en guatemala el 23 por ciento de la
población tiene la dosis completa una
sola dosis el 11 por ciento un total del
33 por ciento de los guatemaltecos ya
están vacunados vamos a colombia cierran
esta semana con el 48 por ciento de la
población con las dos dosis completas o
esquema completo de vacunación
dependiendo del tipo de vacuna que hayan
recibido 25% de la población tiene una
sola dosis un total del 73 por ciento de
la población ya tiene algún tipo de
inmunización chile el líder de la región
84,14 por ciento de la población tiene
el esquema completo una sola dosis el 3
71 % del 87 85% de la población chilena
está vacunada vamos a terminar en
bolivia allí el 35 por ciento de la
población tiene el esquema completo una
sola dosis 7.79 por ciento el 42 88 por
ciento de la ciudadanía tiene el esquema
completo de vacunación
nos vamos a ir ahora hasta eeuu en donde
hubo varios temas y anuncios importantes
a lo largo de esta semana ante la
detección de varios casos de la variante
omicron en la unión americana mamen sala
en la ciudad de nueva york que nos da
más detalles hola mamá en gracias por
acompañarnos en el programa y que se
saben de estos casos que fueron
detectados en eeuu a lo largo de esta
semana cuéntenos
[Música]
se han registrado de momento cinco casos
de omicron elevando a seis el número de
estados en todo el país que ya han
detectado pacientes con esta nueva
variante estos son colorado california
minesota hawai y nebraska que lo acaban
de anunciar precisamente hoy viernes la
mayoría de estos pacientes afectados por
la nueva variante estaban vacunados y
están presentando síntomas leves algún
dolor de cabeza un poco de todos quizás
salvo el de hawai que no estaba vacunado
y sus síntomas son un poquito más
fuertes el caso de california que fue el
primero que conocimos en este país el
pasado miércoles se trata de una persona
que estaba vacunada y que había viajado
recientemente a sudáfrica en el caso de
nueva yor de esas 5 personas que se
encuentran contagiadas conocemos el caso
de una mujer que tiene 67 años también
estaba completamente vacunado tan solo
tiene un poco de dolor de cabeza y hay
un poquito de todos pero síntomas leves
y también había viajado recientemente a
sudáfrica al parecer el test que se
realizó el 25 de noviembre dio negativo
pero este martes otro test que se había
realizado dio positivo y entonces ya se
investigó un poquito más y se descubrió
que estaba afectada por la nueva
variante o picón ante estos nuevos datos
los funcionarios de salud en eeuu
reconocen que es inevitable esta nueva
variante avance y se extienda por el
país de manera rápida también hablemos
de las medidas que ha impuesto el
gobierno federal a partir de estos casos
de omicron encontrados hay en eeuu que
dicen
sé santiago más vacunas más 319 y más
control de los viajeros internacionales
esas son las principales líneas de la
estrategia de joe biden para luchar
contra esta nueva variante omicron así
que mucha atención a aquellas personas
que quieran viajar a eeuu porque a
partir del lunes será obligatorio no
solamente estar vacunado también
presentar una pcr negativa o antes
antígeno realizado 24 horas antes de
el avión hasta ahora al margen era
mucho mayor se dejaban hasta tres días
para realizar esa prueba antes de viajar
se descartan de momento las cuarentenas
aunque siguen sobre la mesa por si la
situación se complicará porque no
debemos olvidar que en este país 3 de
cada 10 estadounidenses no tienen puesta
la pauta completa de vacunación y más de
1300 personas se están muriendo al día
por kobe 19 así que otra de las líneas
de joe biden es precisamente ampliar
esas pruebas de kobe que la gente tenga
un mayor acceso a ellas que pueda
hacerlo desde casa y que además sean
gratuitas también se lanzará una campaña
para convencer a la población de que se
ponga tercera dosis de refuerzo y
también para convencer a aquellos que
todavía no se han puesto ni siquiera un
pinchazo para que lo hagan remarcando la
importancia de la vacuna para luchar
contra esta nueva variante omicron
importancia de la vacuna am avn entonces
cómo avanza la vacunación en eeuu que ha
venido bajando la tasa a nivel nacional
a lo largo de los últimos meses muy
lentamente pero bien en bajada
si santiago aquí el gobierno y las
autoridades sanitarias no dejan de
insistir de que la mejor manera de
combatir esta nueva variante es sin duda
es con la vacuna a pesar de que todavía
no se tenga mucha información sobre un
micrón y también por supuesto con el uso
de las mascarillas que de hecho yoga y
de las ha incorporado también a su
estrategia de ataque contra esta nueva
variante las ha vuelto a imponer ha
vuelto a imponer su uso en el transporte
en todo el país y además cada vez las
estamos viendo más en interiores no
debemos olvidar que en eeuu sólo el 60%
de la población está completamente
vacunado al cien millones de personas en
este país que se niegan a ponerse es el
primer pinchazo a pesar de que estemos
viendo una media de 94 mil nuevos casos
diarios de kobe 19 el gran problema lo
estamos viendo en los estados más
republicanos como en wyoming por ejemplo
donde la población vacunada es sólo un
45% también lo vemos en dakota del norte
alabama y luisiana donde la población
vacunada no llega al 49% algo que
contrasta mucho con otros
como por ejemplo el de nueva yor aquí
más del 70% de la población está
vacunada y mucho mejor lo están haciendo
con ética y vermont que tienen más del
72 por ciento de sus ciudadanos
completamente inmunizados
amén muchas gracias por este completo
reporte desde la ciudad de nueva york en
mam en sala nuestra corresponsal en la
gran manzana la unión europea volvió a
entrar en el debate de imponer la
obligatoriedad de la vacunación en el
bloque comunitario la tasa de vacunación
alcanza apenas el 66 por ciento por eso
la presidenta de la comisión europea
úrsula von der leyen afirmó que el tema
debe ser sometido a debate en el bloque
de los 27
es una cuestión que se plantea en todo
el continente deben los países de la
unión europea hacer obligatorias las
vacunas contra el kobe 19 mientras la
variante omicron se extiende por europa
austria y alemania se han mostrado
favorables a la obligatoriedad la
comisión europea dijo el miércoles que
los países deberían estar abiertos al
debate
av
a ver cómo podemos fomentar y pensar
potencialmente en la vacunación
obligatoria dentro de la unión europea
esto necesita un debate esto necesita un
enfoque común pero es una discusión que
creo que tiene que ser dirigida a cinco
civiles en francia las tasas de
vacunación son altas en torno al 75 por
ciento aunque 6 millones de personas aún
no se han vacunado algunos expertos
sostienen que lo importante no es
centrarse en obligar sino en convencer a
la gente de que se vacune en primer
lugar
báscolo visitado lo importante es
convencer a las personas de que se
vacunen lo antes posible ya sea la
primera la segunda o la tercera dosis de
luz
cada país de la unión europea ha
adoptado una postura diferente respecto
a la implantación de la vacuna
el secretario de sanidad de reino unido
dijo la semana pasada que no cree que
vayan a hacer obligatorias las vacunas
mientras que grecia es el primer país
que especifica un límite de edad con un
mandato para los mayores de 60 años la
tasa de vacunación en la unión europea
se sitúa en el 66 por ciento
aproximadamente un tercio de la
población
y esta semana perú como ya lo decíamos
detectó su primer caso de la variante o
micro vamos a ver qué información hay en
torno a este tema qué medidas ha tomado
allí el gobierno vamos a hablar con
francisco zacarías nuestro corresponsal
en la ciudad de lima hola francisco
gracias por estar con nosotros en el
programa y resumamos los hechos que ha
habido a lo largo de esta semana a raíz
del hallazgo de este primer caso de
omikron perú
hola santiago un peruano de ascendencia
nipona tras salir de japón llegó a perú
el 27 de octubre último luego se
trasladó a la región de piura en el
norte del perú donde estuvo 20 días se
casó y celebró una fiesta después
retornó a lima para viajar el 24 de
noviembre a sao paulo y luego a qatar
llegó a japón el 27 de noviembre y el 1
de diciembre el gobierno japonés reportó
este peruano con el virus esto encendió
la alarma sobre la presencia de omicron
en perú el ministerio de salud de ese
país tras intercambiar información con
las autoridades japonesas ubicó al
esposo en piura
ella presenta síntomas leves como fiebre
y dolor de garganta las autoridades
locales la mantienen aislada y tienen un
cerco epidemiológico a 20 contactos
directos e indirectos 10 de ellos
participaron en la pequeña fiesta sin
usar mascarillas horas antes el
instituto nacional de salud no
descartaba que el joven peruano
detectado como micro en japón haya
adquirido la nueva variante del virus en
perú del mismo modo el colegio médico de
este país había adelantado una eventual
circulación del micro en perú
francisco hablemos entonces de lo que
han dicho las autoridades en cuanto a
restricciones cuidados prevención
después de haber encontrado este primer
caso
el gobierno peruano ha adelantado las
restricciones para los no vacunados a
partir del 10 de diciembre los
ciudadanos mayores de 18 años que deseen
ingresar a espacios cerrados tendrán que
mostrar el significado de vacunación con
las dos dosis contra el kobe y 19 del
mismo modo las personas que quieran
viajar por transporte aéreo terrestre
deberán exhibir el carnet de vacunación
con el esquema completo las fronteras
que estaban previstas ser abiertas los
primeros días de diciembre ya no podrán
hacerlo el gobierno ordenó el cierre de
fronteras de perú con sus países vecinos
para la celebración de la navidad y el
año nuevo las autoridades tienen
previsto adelantar el horario al toque
de queda después de la medianoche además
a toda persona que venga desde sudáfrica
o países alrededor de áfrica o donde
existe infección comunitaria demostrada
se le exigirá el carnet de vacunación
completo y una prueba molecular de no
más de 48 horas de antigüedad mientras
tanto el ministerio de salud ha lanzado
una alerta epidemiológica a los
establecimientos sanitarios públicos y
privados para contener la variante un
micro francisco y para terminar
hablemos de la vacunación pregunta
obligatoria como avanzado allí en perú
sí bien pero tiene casi 19 millones de
personas inmunizadas con dos dosis de la
vacuna contra el cob y 19 que representa
el 67 por ciento de la población
objetivo las autoridades son conscientes
de que todavía no se ha alcanzado la
cobertura de vacunación que podría ser
pensar que el país estaría libre como
sociedad de la transmisión del virus por
eso ante la amenaza de la variante o
micro se invoca a los peruanos a
completar su vacunación y continuar con
las medidas de prevención como el uso de
mascarillas
distanciamiento físico y evitar los
lugares cerrados pero está sufriendo un
notable incremento de casos de kobe 19
persie minaya ex viceministro de salud
señaló que todavía no se sabe si la
variante podría ser de alguna forma
responsable del incremento de contagios
de ahí la preocupación de las
autoridades por un importante 33% de los
peruanos que no se han vacunado y se
encuentran totalmente expuestos al cob y
19 francisco pues el llamado es a la
vacunación y al cuidado muchas gracias
por este reporte desde la ciudad de lima
la capital de perú mientras tanto en
ecuador las medidas para evitar el
avance de la planta y también la
eventual llegada de la variante omicron
van desde el aplazamiento de la fecha
para el regreso a clases presenciales
como una reducción también del aforo en
algunos lugares cerrados también hay
nuevas condiciones para la reapertura de
la frontera con colombia
nuevas reglas por la variante omicron
ecuador tomó la determinación de imponer
condiciones a la apertura de la frontera
con colombia la apertura de la frontera
con nuestro vecino país de colombia será
por fases y la primera contempla el
transporte internacional de mercadería
cumpliendo protocolos de bioseguridad
según los acuerdos entre los ministerios
de transporte de los dos países
además los gobiernos de los dos países
aumentaron la campaña de vacunación en
la frontera
los gobiernos de ecuador y colombia
intensificaron desde este primero de
diciembre la vacunación contra kobe 19
en la zona fronteriza y en la ciudad de
ipiales perteneciente al departamento de
nariño la variante también hizo que el
gobierno de guillermo lazo ampliará la
administración de vacunas de refuerzo a
todos los mayores de 18 años la fecha
prevista para iniciar esta etapa era
enero de 2022 los elegibles son aquellos
que hayan sido vacunados con las dos
dosis seis meses antes otra medida fue
aplazar el retorno presencial a los
establecimientos educativos que estaba
prevista para diciembre y enero las
autoridades también tomaron medidas de
prevención que incluyen un aforo máximo
de 50% en espacios abiertos o cerrados
según un conteo de la universidad johns
hopkins ecuador registra más de 526.000
contagios y unas 33.000 muertes por el
cob y 19 en colombia por su parte el
carnet de vacunación con una dosis se
exige a partir del 30 de noviembre a
mayores de 12 años
a restaurantes museos cines parques de
diversiones o ferias a partir del 14 de
diciembre se exigirán las dos dosis de
vacunación
nos vamos hasta el norte del continente
canadá fue el primer país del continente
americano en reportar los primeros casos
de contagio de la variante omicron 1 en
la provincia de ontario y otro en la
provincia de québec vamos entonces hasta
toronto allí se encuentra daniel favor a
nuestro corresponsal allí en esta ciudad
canadiense para conocer más detalles
daniel de los detalles entonces de lo
sucedido a lo largo de esta semana en
canadá y estos casos de omicron en este
país
santiago un saludo desde toronto canadá
y si la cepa omicron ya es una realidad
en todo el país en varias provincias por
lo menos en las principales ha
aterrizado el día martes en quebec con
un caso también se han reportado dos
casos adicionales uno en british
columbia y otro en alberta también el
día martes en esta provincia en ontario
tenemos seis casos repartidos en las
municipalidades aquí en la gran zona de
toronto hay cinco casos en hamilton hay
otro caso con síntomas muy similares a
lo que podría ser esta cepa de omicron
hay que decir que el premier de esta
provincia que es de oxford que se
caracteriza siempre por ser muy prudente
ha dicho que sí que hay que estar muy
preocupados pero que no hay que entrar
en pánico que ya hemos tenido
experiencias similares con la cepa delta
y que se han afrontado pues con toda la
responsabilidad del caso así que este
país está preparado para hacerlo también
se ha dicho desde salud canadá que hay
que estar preparados y que también hay
que afrontarlo como se ha afrontado el
commit desde inicios de la pandemia con
distancia social con el uso de la
máscara y también con el lavado de manos
danielle entonces después de haber
detectado estos casos de omicron en
canadá qué medidas tomaron las
autoridades
si en estos momentos hay un incremento
en los casos registrados de kobe en el
país aproximadamente dos mil 954 casos
diariamente esto es un pico del 34% muy
similar a lo sucedido en abril de este
año razón por la cual las medidas han
regresado en el tiempo a seis meses en
estos momentos las medidas para entrar a
este país son las que había entre abril
mayo y junio cuáles son esas medidas las
personas que tienen derecho de entrar a
este país porque son ciudadanos o porque
los cobija la ley india o porque son
residentes permanentes pueden entrar
pero tienen que llegar a hacerse una
prueba de covite molecular en el
aeropuerto a los 8 días tienen que
hacerse otra prueba que les dan en el
aeropuerto se la tienen que hacer ellos
personalmente el estado pasa y la recoge
pero también a la llegada al aeropuerto
tienen que presentar un plan sólido de
cuarentena por 14 días un sitio donde
vayan a estar aislados si no tienen este
plan no es que no nos vayan a dejar
entrar al país pero el estado podría
proveerles un sitio para pasar la
cuarentena lo cual es muy acoso porque
en muchos casos son hoteles que son un
poco costosos así que así están las
cosas en estos momentos en canadá
cuarentena y para las personas que
vienen de países de 10 países de áfrica
especialmente del sur de áfrica la
entrada está prohibida en estos momentos
danielle y finalmente para terminar este
contacto la vacunación como está
avanzando allí en canadá
si la vacunación va muy bien en canadá
aproximadamente un 78% de la población
tiene una dosis y el 75% de la población
tiene también dos dosis hay que decir
que esta semana se produjo una gran
noticia y es que las personas mayores de
50 años ya son elegibles para una
tercera dosis antes solamente era
posible para personas entre 70 años y 80
años en adelante porque son las más
vulnerables también noticias que tienen
que ver con adolescentes y niños los
adolescentes de colegios que están en
actividades extracurriculares como
torneos deportivos son también elegibles
para una tercera dosis y los niños que
tienen inmunodeficiencias también están
en esta lista de espera ha dicho yo sin
trudeau que canadá no tiene problemas en
abastecimiento de vacunas que hay
suficientes que el gran reto es saber
cómo las van a distribuir y ha
recomendado que las personas que están
llegando a canadá descarguen la
aplicación a ride camp donde puedan
poner sus datos de inmigración poner
cuántas vacunas tienen es una vuelta que
tienen que antes de llegar al aeropuerto
si no la hacen y tienen problemas con la
tecnología lo pueden hacer a la llegada
llenando una forma pero obviamente esto
va a demorar un poco más su entrada a
este país danielle muchas gracias por
este reporte desde la ciudad de toronto
en canadá y con esto llegamos al final
del programa kobe 19 la semana en
américa los invito a seguirse cuidando
seguir usando el tapabocas y lavándose
la mano nos vemos la próxima semana
sigan viendo france24
[Música]